Hallo guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagann, ich bin hier aus dieser Bandarstätik und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Annäusegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne über Schätz sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Besprechung sprechen, möchte ich ganz finale Einfragen und eine Frage an Sie stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja. Danke. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Melanie Schlewing. Können Sie Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, S-C-H-L-I-N-G.
Frau Schlewing, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren? Am 14. Februar 1986.
Frau Schlewing, wie groß sind Sie? 1,74 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie? 68 kg.
Frau Schlewing, was führt Sie zu uns? Was für eine Bechelde haben Sie momentan?
Vor zwei Stunden habe ich plötzlich starke Luftnot und Schmerzen im Brustkorb, mehr auf der linken Seite, hinten.
Momentan haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Ich habe jetzt auch Brustschmerzen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Stähend oder brennend oder pochend?
Stähend.
Frau Schlewing, ich möchte Sie mit dem Monitor anschließen und Ihre Sauerstoffsättigung messen.
Gegenwünschtefalls werde ich Ihnen auch Sauerstoff geben und werde auch eine EKG schreiben lassen.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Jetzt haben wir alles gemacht und sind alles in Ordnung.
Können Sie eine Luftnot oder einen starken Brustschmerz haben?
Sie haben vor zwei Stunden eine Luftnot und plötzlich die Schmerzen gehabt.
Siebte Schmerzen haben auch in der linken Seite ausgestrahlt.
Und noch andere Körperteile ausgestrahlt.
Nein, das ist mehr so hinter der Achselhöhe, hinten am Brustkorb.
Da ist das schlecht.
Auch wenn ich tief Luft hole.
Am schlimmsten ist die Luftnot.
Genau.
Und linksseitige Achselhöhe.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auch bei einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichter.
10 sehr starker Schmerzen meint?
Sieben.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für diese Schmerzen?
Und für diese Luftnot?
Die waren plötzlich, das ging sofort.
Mit einem Schlag war das da richtig keine Luft mehr und es war ganz schlimm.
Beide sind gleichzeitig aufgetreten.
Ziemlich gleichzeitig.
Aber zuerst war plötzlich diese Luftnot.
Dann schlug das Herz auch ziemlich schnell.
Leider sind unter Herzschlagen.
Das Herz geht doch schneller als normal.
Hatten Sie früher endlich überschwertet?
Noch nie.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung, dass Sie hierher gekommen sind.
Natürlich müssen wir alle andere Diagnose auslösen.
Und müssen wir weitere aparative Diagnostik kuscheln.
Und haben Sie, Brustschmerzen habe ich gesagt,
und leiden Sie auch unter Luftnot, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Hast du Schmerzen bei dem Wasser lassen oder mit einem Sturrgang?
Nein, bis vor zwei Stunden war ich ziemlich gesund.
Leider sind unter Herzschlagen und durchschwarten?
Nein, alles gut.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Das ist normal.
Ich habe jetzt mal ein paar Schmerzen.
Ich habe nun einen Appetit.
Das ist normal.
Im Augenblick mag ich jetzt nichts essen, weil es geht mir nicht gut.
Genau, ja.
Das ist ein bisschen schlecht.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewert ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht immer gehalten.
Ich mache regelmäßig Sport.
Können Sie normalerweise gut schlafen?
Ja.
Können Sie ohne Atem noch zubekommen?
Ja, das kann ich.
Wie viele Meter können Sie laufen ohne Schmerzen?
Oder ohne Atem noch zubekommen?
Jetzt, wo ich das sage, gut.
Genau, ja, jetzt.
Ich fiel fünf Meter.
Haben Sie angeschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Mein linkes Bein ist ja geschwollene, seitdem ich
vor ungefähr acht Tagen umgeknickt bin beim Joggen.
Okay, vor acht Tagen.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Vor acht Tagen, ungefähr.
Ja, vor acht Tagen bin ich umgeknickt.
Beim Joggen bin ich mit dem linken Fuß umgeknickt.
Okay.
Seitdem habe ich dort eine starke Schwellung.
Ich habe immer viel mit Eis und habe das gewickelt.
Ja, es ist geschwollen.
Okay, vor acht Tagen habe ich sie umgeknickt.
Haben Sie lange Reise gehabt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Hautveränderungen an diesem Bereich bemerkt?
Nein, nur die Haut ist etwas gespannt,
weil es ja viel dicker ist da unten.
Ich habe es nicht mehr gemacht.
Haben Sie kälte oder wärmegefühle gefolgt,
auch dort an diesem Bereich bemerkt?
Nein.
Man sieht jetzt dort schon ein Bluterguss.
Ja, okay.
Wie ein Bluterguss, dort, Ersammlung.
Es ist alles dunkelblau gefärbt jetzt.
Ja, das ist ein Bluterguss.
Es ist ein Bluterguss.
Es ist alles dunkelblau gefärbt jetzt.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiben Sie an einer bestimmten Vorerkrankung,
vor der ich wissen sollte, z.B. Bluthochdruck
oder Diabetes Militostips, Brutzkalkrankheit
oder schultersehr über Funktion?
Ich habe schon seit der Jugend, habe ich Asthma.
Asthma, seit wann?
Seit meiner Jugend.
Ja, okay, seit der Jugend.
Und dann nehme ich Asthma-Spray.
Ein Spray nehme ich ein bis zweimal am Tag,
das soll ich immer nehmen.
Und ein Spray soll ich nehmen, bevor ich Sport mache,
wenn ich joggen gehe.
Eine Spray nehme ich zweimal am Tag.
Aber regelmäßig, ja.
Ich nehme zweimal am Tag, je nachdem,
wenn es im Winter sehr neblig ist und feucht ist,
dann brauche ich zweimal, im Sommer vielleicht einmal.
Okay.
Und andere Vorerkrankungen
oder chronische Erkrankungen,
haben Sie da unter?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Ich bin als Kind am Blindarm operiert worden.
Aber sonst, nein, sonst fühle ich mich drunter.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und diese blindarm Enternung war kostbar?
Ich war 11 Jahre alt.
11 Jahre alt, okay.
Komplikationslos ist herlaufen.
Das war alles gut.
Ansonsten keine weitere Operationen
und keine weitere Vorerkrankungen haben Sie.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein,
abgesehen von dieser Spray?
Ich nehme einmal Asthma Spray, das heißt Atma Disc.
Asthma Disc und Salbutamol Spray,
nehme ich vor dem Sport.
Vor dem Sport können Sie wiederholen,
diese Name?
Salbutamol.
Wie viel Milligramm oder wie viel Milliliter?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe das in der Eile nicht mitgenommen.
Muss ich noch besorgen.
Medikamandliste haben Sie nicht dabei?
Nein, sonst nehme ich noch die Pille.
Zur Verhütung, oder?
Ja.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch, Frau Schläbing?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Sind bei Ihnen Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, ich vertrage alles.
Ich esse wenig Fleisch, aber ich vertrage alles.
Das ist gut.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Ist das schon?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends beim Abendessen ein kleines Glas Wein.
Aber das ist nicht viel.
Ich habe noch ein Glas Wein.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine medisische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Drogen nehmen.
Nein, das nehme ich nicht.
Können Sie gut Sport treiben?
Ich bin zu dieser Spray.
Ich habe eine Spray.
Ich kann eine Stunde joggen.
Ich mache das 3-mal in der Woche.
Ja, okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Ich war vor einem Vierteljahr
zwei Wochen in Italien.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorstellig gegen Corona
und andere Impfungen?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft gegen Corona.
Normalerweise habe ich alle nötigen Impfungen.
Ich muss ein paar Fragen über Ihre Medizin.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich muss ein paar Fragen über Ihre Mestration.
Frauen an einem Nase fragen.
Haben Sie Mestrationsbeschwerden?
Nein.
Sind alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Das ist gut.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen
nach Ihrer Familiengeschichte fragen.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe eine Tochter, 9 Jahre alt.
Sie ist gesund.
Mit wem sind Sie zusammen?
Mit der Familie.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist 39 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Asthma.
Er nimmt Medikamente?
Er nimmt auch einen Spray.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau, welchen.
Leber ich in der Elbphilharmonie?
Ja.
Der Vater ist 72 Jahre alt.
Er hat etwas hohen Blutdruck.
Und etwas Zucker.
Er ist 71 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Asthma.
Ich habe auch etwas Neurodermitis.
Sie haben ja.
Und meine Mutter.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Nein.
Das ist auch nicht so schlimm.
Aber manchmal im Winter wird es etwas schlimmer.
Aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
Seit wann leiden Sie an diese Neurodermitis?
Seit wann?
Das begann auch so.
Im Jugend.
Und Ihr Bruder hat Neurodermitis?
Ja.
Ihr Mutter hat Asthma.
Und sie hat eine andere Mutter.
Ja, die Mutter hat Asthma.
Und jetzt wurde sie behandelt.
Ja.
Die Mutter bekommt auch Asthma-Mittel.
Aber die Mutter lebt in einer anderen Stadt.
Die Eltern, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Mittel sie nimmt.
Okay.
Frau Schneewing, was machen Sie aus der Welt?
Ich bin Architektin.
Architektin, ja.
Sind Sie auf der Arbeit zufrieden?
Ja.
Haben Sie Stress?
Manchmal schon.
Wenn es Probleme gibt beim Bau
bei den Häusern.
Aber das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Aber Sie können damit umgehen?
Ja, das ist schon.
Frau Schneewing, von meiner Seite habe ich
alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestellt.
Haben wir etwas vergessen, was wichtig sein könnte?
Fertig noch etwas ein?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, meine Hauptfrage ist, was ist das?
Okay, ich möchte eine kurze Umfassung für Sie machen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie vor zwei Stunden
eine Brustschmerzen und Brustnot bekommen haben.
Diese Schmerzen sind hinter dem Brust aufgetreten.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Von Ihnen werde ich Brut abnehmen.
Ich werde wieder eine EKG schreiben.
Eine Long-Gang-Aufnahme.
2 Ebenen Brustgenaufnahme werde ich für Sie veranlasst.
Ich werde Sie aufgerufen.
Nach dieser Befundung werde ich mit dem Obenas sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich zu Ihnen kommen.
Ich sage Ihnen, was zu tun ist.
Aber zuerst müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Wir werden Sie mit dem Monitor angeschlossen.
Wir werden Sie bei Wir Campeur verсудet.
Alle Schriftenden werden Sie von uns aufgerufen.
Okay, so können wir machen.
Danke Ihnen.
Ich habe auch eine Fragen zum Sie expressionierten.
ropa
dann eine elastische Bandage genommen und das gewickelt. Mein Mann hat immer gesagt,
ich muss zum Arzt gehen damit, habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Okay, gibt es einen unterschiedlichen, ich sehe derzeit einen Atemnot und ich habe
Asthma. Ja, das ist etwas ganz anderes. Also Asthma, da kommt eventuell die Luftnot
langsam mal oder es wird langsam etwas enger, aber das war jetzt ganz akut, ganz plötzlich.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß oder Kalten Schweiß entschuldigung, haben Sie jetzt momentan Kalten
Schweiß? Ja, vielleicht war ich danach etwas verschwickalschweißig, das war auch so ein
Schock für mich dieser Schmerz und die Luftmord. Okay, das war es, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen? Gut.
Als wir anfangen können wir anfangen, Memedemin? Ja, können wir anfangen.
Bitte schön. Gut. Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, hätten Sie kurz der Zeit für mich.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Frau Melania Schlewig ist eine 36 Jahre alt und 1,74 Meter groß und 68 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Melania Schlewig hat sie heute bei uns wegen vor zwei Stunden aufgetretener Luftnot und
Brustschmerzen vorgestellt, wie Schmerzen sein Blöstung aufgetreten und sein Stehend und
Retrosternar. Und die Schmerzen würden in den links Achselhölle ausstrahlen, wie Schmerzintensis
liegen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10 bei 7 und des Weiteren klackte der Patient über
eine Kartschweiß- und Herzschlag. Und wegen dieser Schmerzen könne der Patient nur 5 Meter
hinaufgehen laufen. Und diese beiden Brustschmerzen und Retrosternar Brustschmerzen und Luftnot
oder Düfne würden begleitet auftrennen. Und der Patient berichtet, außer der berichtet die Patientin,
sei sie vor acht Tagen am linken Knie umgeknickt. Am linken Knie oder am linken Spulgelenk? Am linken
Spulgelenk, genau, am linken Spulgelenk umgeknickt und die Spulgelenk sei dicker geworden und
angeschwollt und habe sie an diesem Bereich Hematom bemerkt. Die Patientin berichtet über eine
Distortion, links OSG oder Spulgelenk vor acht Tagen mit Schwellung und Hematombildung.
Ja, mit Schwellung und Hematombildung, ja. Distortion, richtig? Ja, und die Wege zu
anderen Seite sei unauffällig, wie es auch eine Kartschweiß- und Herzschlag. Ist diese Distortion
behandelt worden in der Ambulanz oder? Nicht behandelt worden, die Patientin habe diese
selbst verband gemacht und habe selbst behandelt, aber nicht in einem Krankenhaus behandelt worden.
Okay, gibt es Risikofaktoren sonst bei der Patientin? Genau, natürlich für diese
Lungenembolie oder für diese andere, ja, für die linken Embolie ist es ein bis eine Risikofaktor.
Okay, gut. Das ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose? Lungenembolie, meine Verdachtstiagnose, ja.
Und an Vorerkrankungen nannte die Patientin eine Neurodermitis seit jungen Jahren und dagegen
nehmt der Patient keine Medikamente ein, ist nicht medikamentös bedürftig. Sie ist,
ja, und seit Jugendjahren leidet die Patientin ein, einer Asthma, dagegen nehmen sie eine Atmardisk,
zweimal ein, zweimal am Tag ein. Du passiert den Atmabrontiale und eine Basismedikation mit
Atmardisk, ja. Ja, eine Basismedikation mit Atmardisk, zweimal am Tag ein, im Winter zweimal
und im Sommer einmal, wenn es warm ist, eine Supri, saubutemmel Supri, bevor sie einen Sport
treiben möchte. Okay, und was treibt die Patientin für den Sport? Jogi. Jogi, okay. Genau, ja. Und
als Kind sei eine Appendectomy durchgeputzt worden im Alter von elf Jahren und die Patientin
nehme viele zur Verhütung und Frauen an einem es sei unauffällig und die Patientin und Allergie und
Unverhältlichkeiten wurden verneint. Die Patientin trinkte Alkohol ein kleines Glas Wein abends
gelegentlich und Drogenkonsum und Nikotinkonsum wurden verneint. Die Patientin und Reiseanamter
sie oder die Frage nach Reiseanamter sie oder ja, die Patientin sei am 2. Mai vor fünf Monaten
zwei Wochen lang in Italien gewesen. Okay, gut. Jetzt glaube ich keine, keine Auffälligkeit.
Ankung jetzt nicht so relevant. Genau, nicht so relevant. Es geht ein kompletter Impfschutz.
Genau, vollständig geimpft. Die Patientin sei vollständig geimpft und sei verheiratet und habe
eine gesunde Tochter und lebt mit seiner mit ihrer Familie zusammen und habe einen einen Bruder
der 39 Jahre alt sei und der auch leider an einer Asthma-Brunchale und nur der Militist auch und
der Vater der Patientin lebe noch und sei 72 Jahre alt und leider an einer Artheole Hypertonie und
Diabetes Militist und die Mutter der Patientin sei 71 Jahre alt und leider an einer Asthma-Brunchale.
Also gibt es diese Asthma-Belastung wahrscheinlich über die Mutter? Ja, genau.
Belastung in der Familie, ja gut. Und Ihre Verdachtstiagnose haben Sie eben schon genannt? Ja,
und differenzial diagnostisch? Ja, aus differenzialen Domäsen kommen die zum Beispiel eine
chronische Herzkrankheit in Betrat oder können wir auch eine Myocardinfarktis in Betrat oder können
wir auch nennen. Pynomotorax? Pynomotorax natürlich für junge Menschen, Pynomotorax auch eine gute
differenzial Diagnose sein. Wahrscheinlich muss man jetzt doch an eine Lungenembolide denken,
der Akute beginnen mit der Luftnot, dann der betonte Herzschlag, dann vor dem Hintergrund eines
Traumers, Distortionstrauma vor acht Tagen, bisher nicht diagnostiziert oder nicht behandelt,
ohne Heparinschutz mit selbst bewickelt, daraus können ja häufig dann leider Embolien entstehen.
Genau, ja, müssen wir als erst diese Embolie ausfließen, dann andere Diagnose zum
Ausschluss, andere Diagnose, Diagnose sichermassnahmen durchschülern. Aber Sie haben ja schon in der
Notaufnahme zumindest die Vitalwerte kontrolliert, SPO2, Glutron, ja das war prima. Ja, ich denke,
das ist eine Arbeitsdiagnose, da sollten Sie erst mal mitarbeiten und dementsprechend diagnostizieren
und dann muss man weiter schauen. Ja, also ich finde, Sie haben das auch sehr systematisch und
verständlich gemacht, haben sich bemüht, auch nicht zu lange Sätze zu bilden, was immer ich
wichtig finde, gerade in dem Vorstellungsgespräch, dass man am Ende noch weiß, was man erst am Anfang
gesagt hat. Aber das war gut, versuchen Sie ruhig eben diese Begriffe wie Distortion.
Distortion, ja, wahrscheinlich war es ein Subminationstrauma, die meisten dieser Distorsionen
sind ja Subminationstrauma da. Distorsiontrauma, linkes OSG beim Joggen und selbst behandelt,
also ohne dass jetzt jemand das angeschaut hat oder diagnostiziert hat. Dann wäre es vielleicht
etwas anders behandelt worden von mir aus mit Bewegung, aber wahrscheinlich unter Hipperinschutz.
Ja, gut. Ein gewisser Risikofaktor ist wahrscheinlich die Einnahme auch der Pille,
kann dazu beitragen, aber wahrscheinlich hat die Patientin das sehr ruhig gestellt und hat sich
nicht groß bewegt und das führt hergerne dann zu solchen Komplikationen. Gut, ja. Ja,
aus meiner Sicht finde ich und haben Sie das gut gelöst und haben sich der Diagnose auch gut
genährt und auch gute medizinischen Fachausdrücke eingebaut. Danke.